said you you step into your masculinity
because you don't have a man in your
life
because if we're gonna go for old school
look after your man and he does the
manly roles and he does the car and he
takes out the bins and he does all the
masculine things at the old school
feminists might say if that that person
is because old school there was you know
husband and wife there was not so many
single women like myself right running
households running businesses paying for
cars getting under the Bonnet all of
those things what I'm saying is
sometimes if I were to stick to Old
School feminine ways
I wouldn't get by okay okay I understand
that's what I'm trying to say